hi everyone just before we start I'll
get a show of hands who's played with
your networks it's so a few of you have
had some experience so most of you
haven't really done much with them at
all
I'll talk quickly about what what it
actually is and probably the best way to
start is is to compare it with with
traditional programming which is we
basically do something like this this is
what we do most of the time when we're
programming and if you want to say write
a web page to do something like this
calculate body mass index at the heart
of this is it's an algorithm that this
code works out your body mass index and
essentially we write that algorithm we
figure out what's the formula for this
we write it and then we test it and if
it doesn't work
that means there's a bug in there so we
go back and think what have I done wrong
we change it we fix the bug we test it
again but some kind of problems are
really not conducive to that so if you
were to write a program to say well what
digit what handwritten digit is that you
could divide all that up the pixels and
now you've got a big array of pixels and
how do you write an algorithm to figure
out what what number that is
and this is where machine learning can
can make this a whole lot easier so that
the way a neural network works is give a
high level overview you've got something
that looks like this
so on the input side these are all the
pixels they would all end up in the
input boxes here and then we feed it
into a network of artificial neurons
that the design is loosely inspired by
the way our brain works and the idea
with this is to begin with all of the
internal weights and biases are set to
small random values so it won't work at
the beginning but we start out with a
large set of training data and may
be 50,000 or more images and we feed
those through one at a time so let's say
we feed a fall through that that neural
network it's going to come out with an
answer and it's going to be wrong
because it's not being trained so then
we say what can we do to make it very
slightly less wrong can we modify those
weights and biases to make it a little
bit more likely to be correct then we
repeat the process with all of our
50,000 or so images and we'll have done
that we shuffle the images changed the
order that was called an epoch and we do
it again we do another epoch and we keep
doing this over and over gradually those
weights and biases start to start to
take effect and then this can correctly
infer what the numbers are so we're
going to build this in the next hour but
the question is why what's the advantage
of building why don't we just use a
library because there are a lot of
libraries out there - already to do
machine learning and those libraries
there's nothing wrong with them they're
a great place to end up they're a lot
more sophisticated than what you could
write yourself and they're also faster
because they use the graphics processing
unit the problem though is if you really
want to understand the underlying
principles it's not a good place to
start because that they're all black
boxes with lots of complex knobs and
levers you move a lever and it doesn't
work anymore you don't know what you
don't know why so it's not a good good
way to really understand them from the
bottom up it's rather like if you've
ever flown a flight simulator first
thing you do is you start with something
like this right a big passenger jet but
then you follow a tutorial on how to fly
it
you make one little you get one thing
wrong and it crashes and you don't know
why so you end up going back to
something like this and really learning
the basic stick and rudder skills and
and how to take off a land and then when
you got the hang of that this makes a
lot more sense because when you go
through the tutorial you've got these
conceptual hooks on which to hang your
knowledge so we're going to not only fly
this we're going to actually build this
as well so so really get to understand
it
before we proceed I should make it one
word of warning which is that we're
actually going to be be training to
neural networks right so the the an
artificial neural network and all the
the real human neural networks in your
brain so for the next half an hour or so
I've managed to break this down into it
into something that's a series of fairly
simple concepts training neural networks
is actually fiendishly difficult to
really get your head round but I've
broken this down into a series of simple
concepts but it's essential if you want
to understand that that you pay
attention for about the next half an
hour where we go over those slides and
don't get distracted
otherwise you'll kind of get lost quite
quickly so let's start with it with the
basic concept which is a neuron and what
that is so essentially a neuron it has
it has one or more inputs usually at
least to all those inputs have weights
there's a bias and all of that stuff on
the Left combines to form a total input
goes through an active or scored an
activation function and gives you an
output now take its simplest example is
called a perceptron apperception has a
comparator as the activation function
and it asks a simple question is the
total input greater than zero if so then
it fires a 1 otherwise it outputs a zero
so let's give an example let's imagine
this comparator has three inputs and the
weights are set as as such and the bias
is set to minus 1.5 so let's run some
numbers through that and see what we get
so imagine we have an eight five in
there - if we run that through then we
do that multiplication but the inputs
times the weights we add in the bias and
we can see there we get 0.5 which is
greater than 0 therefore this would
Apple - one like that's pretty much as
as simple as it gets for up for a
perceptron
so let's look at the state of an Iran
there's two aspects to the state there's
the long term state which comprises the
bias and the weights the long term state
determines its behavior and then there's
the transient state so when the neuron
actually fires it has an output and then
there are the intermediate variables we
have in determining the output such as
the the total input so let's see what we
can do with this let's let's try and
make a NAND gate a simple logic gate
which has that the following truth table
if you assign off to zero and on to one
so naught and gate let's see if we can
do that and if we set the bias to three
and the weights to both two - - without
labouring through all the examples that
will work perfectly which means if we
can build a NAND gate with a perceptron
you can build any other kind of logic
gate just from NAND gates so this is
functionally complete we can do anything
just with perceptrons but we could do it
anything before anyway the interesting
bit is is how do we actually how do we
get this thing to learn because I put
those biases and weights in myself I
worked it out
but imagine we didn't know that we're
not they were the interesting bit is can
this learn can it learn from examples
what the correct bias and weights is in
this case so what we do is we start by
initializing these values just to small
random numbers and these are actually
quite big random numbers but for the
sake of the example this this works well
so initial izing as follows and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
put some some training data through
there so I'm going to put a 0 and a 1 in
there let's see what we get we get a 0
on the output because when we take the
combined input when we multiply zero by
point two and add it to 1 times minus
point 3 and then adding the bias we get
a combined input of minus put 4 in there
and that's that's less than 0 so this
outputs are 0 but the output we want in
this case 0 NAND 1 is a 1 so
we've got the wrong result so what we do
is we ask ourselves if we made a little
increase or decrease to those weights of
bias how would that change the output
would it make it a little bit less wrong
or and the problem we've got here is if
we make any small changes nothing is
going to change in the output right we
have to make a really big change for
anything to happen so the problem is
that comparative function looks like
this it's either on or off 1 or 0 it's
not conducive to learning so what we can
do instead we can we can kind of soften
that function we can turn it into
something like this which is called a
logistic sigmoid which has sort of add
values in between it has a gray area so
the other advantage is that when we
start building networks of neurons and
connecting them together this outputs
real numbers right fractional numbers so
that makes a network when we send
fractional numbers to other neurons a
bit more rich and expressive so this
this will work quite well there is a
problem though because if you look at
what the formula is for that that's
relatively expensive to calculate now
remember that we need to be training
this with tens of thousands and
sometimes up to millions and of of
training samples and we may have
thousands and Euron so this isn't isn't
the best kind of formula for something
that you want to calculate quickly so
over the years people have experimented
with simpler formulas to see what works
and they found that something remarkably
simple does a pretty good job called a
rectified linear unit or a Lu and it's
actually much easier to calculate them
to pronounce so with this if X is
greater than zero its X otherwise it's
zero now they've also found that in most
cases we can we can improve this we can
make a better version of the r lu called
a league here le by having having it
leaked on the left hand side so if X is
less than zero it's x over a hundred
that's still really easy fast quick to
calculate that works really well so
now we've got a neuron which outputs
fractional numbers real numbers instead
of whole numbers so in the case of our
NAND gate we still need to interpret the
answer in the end is it up on run off
and to do that is really easy so let's
say it outputs the point two we just say
well point two is closer to a zero than
it is to a one so we'll interpret this
as off rather than on if it was a point
eight would interpret that as on so we
just look at whatever it's closest to
but the important thing now is that
we've actually we can measure the
rightness or wrongness of this so if it
outputs 0.2 and we wanted it to an
output a zero we can say the error is
zero point two the error is the actual
output minus desired output if it
outputted a if the desired output was a
one the error would be a minus 0.8 right
so it seems reasonable that we want to
minimize the error across as many of the
samples as we can right but that there
is a complication in doing this if we if
we simply say let's minimize the total
error across all samples we're not going
to get a very good result imagine we've
got full training samples all of them
have an error of point to all of them it
is got it right remember point if the
error is less than 0.5 it's basically
going to get it right since it's not a
big deal that's a good result very good
outcome imagine now instead we do this
the same thing the first three have an
error of 0 the last one has an error of
0.6 that that's now got the last one
wrong an error of greater than 0.5 we'll
get it wrong but the total error is
lower right with machine learning we
make the rules it follows them if we say
minimize the total error it's going to
favor that bad result over the over the
good result right so what we need to do
is something to to punish those big
errors like 0.6 more than the small
errors like point two and the easiest
thing to do is to square the error first
if we square the
before for adding them up then we're
going to fix that problem we're going to
punish the big errors more than the
small errors so we're not minimizing the
total error we're minimizing something
else which we call the loss the loss is
the variable trying to minimize and we
can define the loss function however we
like but usually for categorizations
issues what we're doing now it's the
error squared summed across all training
samples losses are some of the error
squared where the error is the actual
minus a desired output now a couple of
nuances we could write this instead of
half some error squared identical right
if you try to minimize the sum of the
error squared it's you're going to get
the same result as if you try and
minimize half of the sum of the
earthquake the reason we favor the
second one it creates a nice
mathematical symmetry that we'll see
soon another point is that instead of
putting Sun we could put average and
again it would do exactly the same job
loss is also sometimes called cost cost
loss same thing now here's an
interesting point
we don't usually calculate the loss
which might seem weird if we want to
minimize something surely the first
thing you do is you work out what it is
you're minimizing but you imagine you
know if you think of yourself as a good
driver you're constantly trying to do
things to minimize the chance of an
accident and you might be quite good at
that but if you were if I was to ask you
what is the chance of you having an
accident one in what you probably not
going to be able to tell me right so you
can take actions to minimize something
without actually working it out and if
you look in through a neural network for
the code that squares the error to the
loss you won't usually find it so let's
go back now and plug that leak you Lu it
into our NAND gate so again we start out
with small random values and this time
I'm going to plug a 1 and a 0 in there
so the combined input is now 0
point three right now in this case the
desired output is one the actual output
is also point three because when we put
point three through that value because
it's greater than zero then it's simply
point three it's a one-to-one so now the
error is minus zero point seven so we
can see just from the sign of the error
that we need to increase the output to
reduce the error and the loss a small
increase to the output will have a good
effect you see that so simplest thing we
can possibly say in this case is we need
to increase the output to reduce the
error and the loss so that means we also
need to increase the input why because
we're on the positive side of the rail
you right we're aware so the input and
output in a one-to-one correspondence so
we also need to increase the input which
we could do by increasing that of those
biases and weights a little so what we
could do is now that we've worked out
what we need to do for this training
sample we could take all of the training
samples and repeat the same calculation
and get votes we're saying how many
training samples want to increase the
input how many training samples want to
decrease the input and whichever vote
wins then we make a little adjustment to
the weights and biases and then we
repeat the process again now that would
kind of work you can see intuitively
that would that would help us gradually
improve but what we will be doing is
minimizing the error the total error not
the total loss right we would not be
punishing the big errors more than the
small errors and I remember how
important that is to get a good result
we've got to punish the big errors more
than the small errors so how might we do
that well it's quite simple really
instead of simply getting a vote to
increase or decrease the output we get a
variable number of votes the number of
votes you get is proportional to the
error so in this case the error is minus
foot
so we get zero point seven votes to
increase the output all right if the
error was only minus point one would
only get point one votes to increase the
output right so that way we were the big
errors are waiting much more than the
small errors right and we flipped the
sign because we're trying to minimize
the loss on the error not it not to
maximize it right so that means again we
can say that the input also gets point
seven votes so what we could do now is
we could take all of those training
samples work out the number of votes and
add those votes together and then based
on that we can now make adjustments to
the weights and bias now that would work
and that that's called batched learning
right we collate all the votes for a
large batch or all of our training
samples and once we've got the the total
net votes we may then make the
adjustments but there is actually a
slightly more efficient way we can do
this called stochastic learning
so rather than collating all the votes
up for all the training samples we can
update those biases and weights as we go
along as long as we make really small
changes we can make a change after every
single training sample that avoids
having to do that collation all right so
with stochastic learning what we do is
we take those point seven votes and we
multiply it by little factor called the
learning rate all right in this case
it's 0.01 so when we adjust that we get
put double-oh-seven so now what we do is
we we need to increase the bias by that
amount so the bias becomes put 107 and
we also increase the weight so the first
weight becomes point 207 what about the
second way we've not increased that at
all right why have we not adjusted the
second way rights because the the inputs
0 for the second one there's no point
doing anything to that because it had no
influence on it right so you could only
do harm we don't touch that
right so before increasing or decreasing
the weight we multiply by the value of
the input right that also takes care of
the scenario of this being negative
imagine that was negative one that input
we will need to do the opposite we would
need to decrease the weight in order to
increase the total input why does that
make sense okay so that in a nutshell is
stochastic learning this is how you
train a neuron we've almost covered
everything right there there's one thing
though that I want to touch on which is
that by doing this we are actually
minimizing the total loss the square of
the error and even though we never
worked it out we didn't do any squaring
we're actually doing that I'm going to
for the sake of of interest I'm going to
explain to you how it is that we're
actually now minimizing the square of
the error so if you can't follow this
it's not critical but it is interesting
to see how it works so let's plot on a
graph the input versus the error so we
had an input of 0.3 and an error of
minus 0.7 but you can see from this
graph that if we increase the input a
little bit like we did the error is
going to go down so now let's also plot
this imaginary loss curve this this
graph of the square of the error the
thing we never calculated the thing
which won and minimize that's what it
would look like if we took plot it now
there's a very interesting coincidence
here because if we look at what the
slope of that is at that point it
exactly matches the error it does that
at every point in there and we can prove
this mathematically by differentiating
the loss function right then if you
differentiate y equals 1/2 x squared you
just get y equals x differentiate that
blue line you get the grey line so we
know that the slope is always the same
as the error and that means remember we
took a little step to the right
proportional to that point 7 what that
means is that we travel
down that blue slope at a rate that's
proportional to the slope right imagine
that that's a slide that blue line and
you're sitting on that slide you're
going to start sliding down at a force
proportional to how steep it is this is
called gradient descent we keep taking a
little step in proportion to the slope
now if we were doing batched learning we
batched gradient descent we will just
keep going along that line till we got
to the bottom but because we're doing
stochastic gradient descent we change
that those graphs for every training
sample so we switched to a new training
sample though those are going to look
different now right the error is going
to be in a different place so now let's
say we happen to for the next training
sample the error happened to be z+ 0.35
that would mean we can we would know
that the square of that the loss
function would have a slope of also 0.35
so that means that we would take a
little step to the left not as big as
our last step only half as much right
because we've only got half the error
all right
so the votes corresponds to this to the
negative error which corresponds to the
that the slope of the loss function so
you can see we've taken half of that
step back because it was only 0.35 so we
haven't quite ended up where we started
in fact the position that we've ended up
in is very much the same as the position
we would have ended up in had we done a
gradient descent on the combined loss
for both of those training samples if we
added those two blue lines together and
did a gradient descent on that we would
end up in pretty much the same place
okay so to summarize stochastic gradient
descent for each training sample
determine the slope of the loss function
at the current position but the error
tells a slope that gives us a number of
votes and we step the following amount
minus the slope times our learning rate
and that that's pretty much it to
gradient descent
so let's build it now there's two
samples in this and you can download
those and work through those yourself so
from link pad if you go to the samples
in link pad and click download import
more samples then if you scroll to the
bottom you'll see that the samples for
this for this training session so
they're all they're all in there so you
can work through this yourself
now there's two samples the first one is
this NAND gate for the neuron so this is
how I've created a neuron we've got two
weights in there hard-coded this year on
to have two weights it has a bias and we
start by initializing these two small
random numbers that's it that's all I've
got for the neuron now you're probably
wondering why I've done this but I've
separated the neuron into two classes
it's good programming practice in
general to separate your long-term state
from your transient state so I've
created another class called firing
neuron which captures the transient
state of a neuron firing references the
neuron and has the output and that
intermediate variable total input in
there and this is a method that fires a
neuron we take two inputs the total
input we work that out
it's each input times the corresponding
weight it's exactly what we were doing
to fire it we add in the bias now we
apply the activation function right
there Elliot so all we do is we say if
the input is greater than zero then we
just take the input otherwise we divide
it by hundred that's all it is it's a
simple activation function and this is
how we learn the second one first to
learn we fire the input so we know what
the output is and the total input and
then we work out those output votes
write the output votes is the negative
of the error right so it's just the
expected output minus the output that
tells us how wrong we are and how much
the output needs to change you'll have
the outputs influence on the loss so
then remember we need to multiply by the
slope of the
a function so I just want to go back now
because there's something I didn't
wasn't quite explicit about which is
this situation so the output here got
0.7 votes and the input also got 0.7
votes now imagine that this input here
was actually a negative number so we're
now on the leaky side of the rail you
right so what that would mean is the
input would get how many votes exactly
we divide it by 100 the input will get
point double-oh-seven votes so to work
out how many votes to give the input we
take the output votes we multiply it by
the slope of the activation function
this is the chain rule in calculus if
you didn't understand the chain rule
before you understand it now okay so
that there we are we're multiplying the
by the slope of the activation function
now timidly adjustment we multiplied by
the learning rate that's small that
small point oh one and then we can now
increase the bias by that adjustment and
we can also adjust these weights
remember we multiply the adjustment by
the input so if it's zero it doesn't do
anything if it's minus one it flips it
the other way around so that's it that's
how we learn only other thing here is
the the code to do the training we need
to manufacture some testers and some
TARDIS so I won't go into the code that
I do that with a link query it's
probably easiest just to just to dump it
out so we can have a look at what that
looks like what the training data looks
like so the data simply we've generated
a whole lot of random numbers here and
these are the inputs and this is the
desired output sort of the NAND gate is
functioning properly this is how it
should work we can manufacture as much
training data as we want here really
easy so let's get rid of that so that's
first step is to to manufacture the data
second step is we divide it up into a
training
set and a test set so I'm saying let's
take 80% of that data and we're going to
use that for training we're going to put
the remaining 20% aside for testing
because once we've trained it we don't
really know how accurate it is if we
simply rely on the training data it
might got a very good with that training
data but not so good at generalizing to
data it hasn't seen so we have to we
have to put a separate set of data it
hasn't seen the testing data to know how
good it is so then we train it for each
sample in that training set we call the
learn method on that and you notice I'm
only going through that training set
once I'm only doing one epoch because
normally we would do lots of epochs we
would shuffle the data and do that again
but in this case we have a limitless
amount of training data we don't need to
do that we could if we want more epochs
we could just make more training data
finally I'm doing a report on how
accurate it was so we're firing the
neurons over the testing set and then
we'll just see how many successes and
failures who have got and how that the
error was so we're going to run this now
with a thousand sample so it's 800 for
training 200 for testing and I've set
the learning rate 2.0 - so let's run
this and see what we get now that's the
final state of the neuron it's
automatically worked out from all these
training cycles that these are the other
right weights and biases and it's got
all 200 correct so that hasn't worked
perfectly in there we can also look at
I've also imported on the total error
magnitude and that's a histogram of all
the errors that were been getting and
because none of them are greater than
put 5 it means none of them it's got the
wrong the wrong result so you can have a
lot of fun with this and play with this
and that because this is so simple and
this captures really everything there is
to pretty much - training a neuron you
can learn a lot from this so if we
reduce the total number of samples to a
hundred we'll find that this will no
longer work so we've got 12 correct and
ain't wrong which simply don't have
enough training samples to make the
work we need more than a hundred we
could also see if we if we changed the
learning rate to to say point five
increased the learning rate too much
what happens if the learning rates too
big is it it will oscillate right it
will it will keep going imagine you're
on that slide and you're bouncing you're
sliding down that that's s-curve you get
to the bottom you're going to go up the
other side right so we ended we
oscillate it doesn't work if the
learning rate is too high so you can you
can experiment with all of this and see
how well it works
you can also we can this is a NAND gate
that we're training it to do but we
could quite easily make it do other
kinds of functions if I change this an
to an or it's now going to become an or
gate so we can see whether we can train
it to do an or gate and we can that
works just as well as as an angei but
what about if I try to do an XOR in
there can it do that I put an X or in
this case it all doesn't work right
we've got we've got it's not doesn't
seem to be working at all and this we
try this it will not it will not train
and there's no there's nothing wrong
with our training the problem here is
that you cannot do an exclusive all with
just one year on we need we need a
number of neurons to make this work
right which brings us on to the next
point because right now I did promise
that we would we would build a Cessna
but we're really only built a
hang-glider at this point right because
it's there's there's nothing really very
exciting about her and NAND gate so what
we need to do now is to is is to turn
this neuron into a whole network of
neurons so this is the the architecture
for a neural network we have the inputs
on the left on the far right we have a
layer of output neurons so in the case
of say doing character recognition each
of those those neurons on the right
corresponds to whether it thinks it's
that number so if whichever one gives us
the highest output that's the answer it
thinks it is so that's the output layer
on the right hand side in the middle
anything in the middle we call those the
input layers so the idea is that the
laya connects to to the layer to the
right of it so it's hooked up as a as a
directed acyclic graph so the IMP the
outputs of one year on feed the inputs
of another now there is almost nothing
else that we need to do that we haven't
already done and the process of training
this how do we train a network rather
what's different about training a
network over a single neuron we just
train each neuron so let's start with
that with the firing of the network if
we want to fire the net the whole neural
network we go through each of these
neurons in the hidden layer and we fire
them one at a time then we move to the
right and go to the next hidden layer or
the output layer in this case and we
fire each of these neurons in sequence
and we're moving from left to right when
we're firing the network that's called
feed-forward when we're firing the whole
neural network and imagine we end up
with these outputs we look for whichever
one is the highest which is an eighth
that means it thinks it's an eighth so
we can see from this that big arrows are
going to be worse than small errors just
as with our NAND gate so we would use
the same loss function of an arrow
squared if we wanted to train this so
how do we do the training how do we do
the the training cycle and again very
similar to what we were doing before we
start by with all our output neurons we
go through the monitor time and we run
that same calculation we did before we
work out the output votes right the arm
out which is effectively that the slope
of the loss function so work out the
number of output votes which is the the
output minus the desired output for each
of these then we work out the input
votes exactly the same way but it's the
same as the output votes if the inputs
positive if it's negative we divide by
hundred that's the slope of the rally
now there's one extra step we need to
now go to the hidden layer we go
backwards right this is called back
propagation when you're training a when
you're training a neural network the
process are going from right to left
it's called back propagation so how do
we work out the number of out
pop votes in the hidden layer on these
hidden neurons how do we do that and
it's the simplest thing that could
possibly plausibly work the the number
of output votes you get on a a neuron in
the hidden layer is simply the number of
input votes for all of the the layer to
the right weighted
it's the weighted sum of all of these
input votes here gives you the output
votes for each of these neurons here
that's the only extra bit of information
you need to build a neural net right so
we're going to do this now
and we're going to and I'm going to run
through that example now I won't i won't
labor through the source code there's a
lot more code here but it's just
plumbing it's just hooking all the
neurons up there's only one piece of
extra code here which which we've not
seen really in the next example that's
actually related to the training of the
the training process which is when we
work out the number of output votes so
here we are so when we're working out
the number of output votes in the hidden
neurons we do that weighted sum so we go
to the layer to the right that we just
processed and we do a weighted sum of
all of its input votes times the weight
of that neuron that's the only extra bit
of code related to the actual process of
learning that so I'm going to - we're
going to start running this now I will
make one note on that the fact that with
because we separated the fight that the
the transient state from the long term
states what that meant is that we were
able to easily parallel eyes
so this actually uses all the calls when
your processor and it didn't take much
code to do that at all and there's just
one place where we needed to lock foot
for thread safety so okay so let's run
this now the first thing we need to do
is get some training data there is a
public domain database of training
images there's around 50 with this
50,000 training images of hand
written digits and another 10,000 which
are for testing called the M NIST
database this sample automatically
downloads them from the internet see
you're all ready to go so we creating
your net now the number of input neurons
it has they're not actually neurons
they're just inputs it's the because
it's a square image it's the image width
times the height right we're going to
create one with 20 neurons in the hidden
layer and 10 neurons in the output layer
right then I'm going to train this and
use a learning rate of point O one and
we're going to run this for ten a pox
and then we're going to report on the
failure see how well we've done so let's
run this so this is a first epoch it's
going through it for the first time
ninety-three percent so far 95 percent
with the second one ninety five point
two ninety five point five it keeps
going up with each epoch and eventually
it kind of settles it but that highest
working again so we're up to now after
ninety pox we're up to ninety six point
one percent with the training data
that's the accuracy now with the testing
data it's a bit lower because when we
give it some data it hasn't actually
seen it doesn't usually do quite as well
but in this case it still got ninety
five point four percent accuracy which
is pretty good for thirty brain cells
right this is a home-baked solution with
30 brain cells and we've got ninety five
point four percent accuracy with this
this is all a white box this uses no
libraries you can go and have a look
understand it and play with it so let's
look at the failures with the highest
loss these so these are the ones that
had the most trouble with right these
are the digit you can see that is you
can see why that's quite hard to pick up
that one had a dot in it that confused
it okay so that gives you an idea I
don't even what that is that's supposed
to be that's a six I think it's done
pretty well
so what we're going to do now is I'm
gonna run this again I've written as a
link pad visualizer for the trip for the
trainer which means that you can dump it
and it dumps out a WPF control so we can
watch it learn I'm gonna run this again
and we're going to watch it as it learns
so this now is showing you the color
indicates the bias you can see the bias
taking effect in the color of the of all
of these connectors indicates the
weights so we can watch the weights and
biases it learns right now this is
showing you the hidden layers and the
output layer it doesn't show you all of
the inputs because there's too many it
doesn't show you all of the weights
between the inputs and the hidden layer
because there's too many of those but it
still shows you most of what's
interesting so we can what we can now
see what this kind of neural net looks
like enough also I've got the D I've put
in a pad where we can actually write a
number and then see whether it works
because you know it's one thing just to
run it over these these test images but
it's another thing to actually write
yourself so I'm gonna put it I'm gonna
draw one in there Oh thinks it's a seven
let's try that again put another one in
there it thinks it's a zero now when
something like this happens this is when
you really learn what's going on right
how is it it did so well with that test
data and so poorly but when we actually
use it in practice and when you look at
all of those those training images and
test images what you noticed is that all
of those images are perfectly centered
right so and when they scanned it in
part of the scanning the handwritten was
centering this is not centered so it's
got completely confused right you can
see there's no danger of this neural
network taking over your jobs so there
are two ways that we can fix this one of
them is called data augmentation what we
can do is take our training set and
deliberately shift them all around the
place scale them rotate them add some
noise to them and train those as well
and then it will
how to deal with that that's what
approached the other simpler approach in
this case is we could do exactly the
same thing to this to this canvas that
we that they did to the training data
and we can Center it before feeding into
the network and that's what I'm going to
do so
I already did that I just I just
commented it out so you could see it
fail so now we're gonna run this again I
don't actually need to retrain it but I
haven't written the code to save the the
training data so it's only done three
epochs but we should just be a it should
now work if I put a 1 in its that's
going to get that right and let's put it
let's put something else put a 2 in its
got that put a 5 it's already got that
even though we haven't finished the 5
all right so we've got up two fairly
good training and test accuracy in there
but you know we can do better so what we
could do there's a number of ways we can
improve this so one thing we could do is
add an extra hidden layer so I could put
30 creeps up thirteen-year arms in there
and what another layer with 13 Euron's
and then let's see watch what happens
what we are going to get a better result
but what you tend to find is that when
you add more layers to this kind of
network with this kind of problem while
in theory adding layers should always
make it more expressive and powerful
that it makes the learning much more
likely to go wrong or to be suboptimal
so usually you find that for every kind
of scenario where you create an extra
layer here you can probably do at least
as well by putting all of those neurons
into one hidden layer now this is not
true in all cases but with this kind of
this image recognition this character
recognition you can probably do just as
well with with just getting getting it
into two layers instead of three so but
you can see we're up to 97.7% now just
with our training school 98 now and
let's see what the actual accuracy is
with the test data
we're 97.1 so that's actually not that's
not too bad
we've got it we've got an even even
improved it even more but we would
probably do just as well by putting all
those 16 Euron's into the into the input
layer the other thing I want to show you
is what happens if we if we set that
learning rate too high so if I bump that
up to say porno over five you can
actually watch it watch the the
oscillation can you see the oscillation
in the colors so that's really useful
that visualization because it
immediately tells you if you've got a
problem with the learning rate being
being too high what I've actually done
in this code is I've set it so that the
learning rate automatically gets a
little bit lower with every epoch so as
it becomes more accurate it reduces the
learning rate to prevent overshooting
that the ID or values in there and the
other thing I'm going to do is we'll
store that learning rate we're going to
back this up to let's make it 100
neurons and in so still two layers imma
put a hundred and one of the things I've
done with this they can think of this as
a toolkit for learning is that instead
of hard-coding
the rail you activation function here
have created a pluggable architecture
I've created an activator class and a
subclass fact earlier activator to a
logistic sigmoid activator that other
one we saw before the hyperbolic tangent
a soft Max and I've got an exotic one in
there too which changes the loss
function so you can experiment with
different activation function to see how
that affects the learning and there is
one which is quite cool which I'm going
to put in there now which is an exotic
one called a soft max activator with
cross-entropy loss this actually
modifies the the mathematics is really
complicated but the the algorithm is
actually quite simple so that this
actually modifies the loss function so
no when we were squaring the loss to
punish the big errors more it turns out
you can actually go kind of further with
that you can go even more elaborate in
how you you accurately measure the loss
so that to give it the
best results so I'm going to run this
through now hundred neurons in and and
while this runs I'm gonna I'm going to
touch on another point which is about
gradient descent so if we if we do a
gradient descent on this curve we're
going to end up in that that bottom that
that bottom well now the the the curves
don't normally look like that in that if
you imagine you're doing a gradient
descent on the combined loss for every
training sample it's going to be a
complex Wiggly curve it might end up
looking like that so we can see if we
came in from the left we get stuck in a
local minima here and it wouldn't end up
with a very good result right so this is
one of the reasons why I said we
initialize the weights and values to the
weights and biases to small random
values because by running it again each
time you run it it's going to start from
a different place so that way you can
partly get around this problem by re
running
your training over and over and each
time it will have a different starting
place having said that if you do keep
your your networks relatively simple
with your activation functions and the
number of layers what tends to happen is
that all those minimas are quite close
to each other
so you end up with a situation like this
where if you started from the right
you'd only get a slightly better outcome
than if you started from the left so
let's look back to to the training and
see what's about how well it's doing so
you can see now it's up to ninety-nine
point eight percent accuracy so are we
going to hit a hundred this is a really
good good and active activation function
and it is a loss it is slower than a
rally but we got here we are we got
ninety-nine point eight percent with a
training data but we only got ninety
seven point nine with the actual test
data and that's no better than we would
do if we use a straight value so this
exotic
activation function and loss calculation
has done a lot to bump up our training
accuracy but it hasn't actually helped
with the real-world test accuracy and
this condition is called overfit it's
when it's done a really good job with
the training data and it's locked onto a
lot of specific features of that
training data but it's unable to
generalize well to data it hasn't seen
that's called over fit and that's what
we've got here we would actually be just
as well off with a straight rally and
now one other point I'll mention is what
to do if you don't have much training
data so I said that we need tens of
thousands of rep to millions
I already we already touched on that
that trick of data augmentation where we
can kind of scale and shift and add some
noise to the data before putting it in
but there's something else that you can
do when you don't have much data so
imagine we didn't have that big set of
digits we mention we only had a few
thousand of those but imagine that we
did have a big set of letters from A to
Z what we could do we could train it on
the letters from A to Z if we had 50,000
of those and then once we've got that
nicely trained we can then take that and
we can use that as a starting point to
train the digits which we've only got a
few off and the fact it because letters
and digits are kind of got things in
common it will actually that's called
pre training it will actually get a
better result
so rather than starting off with random
weights and biases you start off with a
network that's already been trained on
some other data that is kind of similar
that's got stuff in common because a lot
of those weights and biases encode kind
of features like you know that you can
think of it as encoding the curves or
the all the straight lines and so on and
these things are in common that's a
really good trick as pre-training you
can use there's something else I should
also mention which is well what we want
to do if we want to take this to the
next level
because to get above 99% it is quite
difficult with the architecture of God
and also the architecture we've got
wouldn't be so conducive to really large
complex images so if we had something
like a photograph with a furry animal in
it and we want to train it to identify
find the furry animal and tell us if
it's a cat or a dog we need something
that's more powerful than this and
essentially what we need to do is with
this neural network this is a
general-purpose neural network that
could solve any kind of problem but what
we can we can do to make it work better
is say look we're just going to make
this work only for images so if we're
going to make design this network just
for images we can do tricks like we can
put filters and feature extraction
filters into the start of that neural
network so it does things like edge
detection or it does things like find
curves or straight lines and then it
feeds those features into the inputs of
the neural network rather than feeding
the raw pixels so the question is then
how do we write those feature extractors
and then how do we decide on what
features to extract and this is where it
kind of gets quite cool because what you
can do is you can you can write a an
image processor but by writing a matrix
of numbers and then scanning that matrix
over the image like doing a dot product
you can then do a transformation on it
in other words you can describe a
transformation purely as a bunch of
numbers now given that you can describe
an image transformation or feature
extraction just as numbers we don't have
to come up with the numbers we can get
the neural network to optimize those
numbers right we can get that back
propagation algorithm to work out what
are the ideal numbers to extract
features so it will work out what
features to extract with only need to
decide on how many layers we want we
don't need to decide on what those
layers will extract right
that's called a convolutional network
convolutional layer does a feature
extraction and image processing and then
feeds that that extracted layer into the
into the next layer so if you're using
the libraries one of the more powerful
features you'll see a options for
convolutional layers and they're really
aimed at image processing and they cut
they're also conducive to having lots of
layers and they're very conducive to
pre-training so you can you can or you
can actually load up pre-trained
convolutional image networks which have
been trained with millions of images
over the Internet and use that as a
starting point for doing image
recognition so I've covered I think I've
covered pretty much everything now and
and are there any questions
okay so when we started out with 20/20
neurons not bring that up again I'll put
20 back in there so there's there's a
couple of points here but the this is
this is just showing you the hidden
layer on the on the left and the output
layer on the right so what we can't see
on here is that there are around 780
input cells they're not neurons s cells
and they're also all the
interconnections between those and the
hidden layer because if we drew them
there just be too much clutter
okay that's a good question how do you
define the optimal learning rate and
that there is kind of no silver bullet
you just experiment you try and
different values and see how it works
and and what you discover is also that
the same value doesn't work well in
every layer so in fact with this network
I I increase the learning rate with
every layer as you go to the right and
that's actually commonly done you need a
higher learning rate as you go to the
right and also I in decrease its
slightly with every epoch I as it
becomes more accurate and so you have to
be careful with a learning rate because
when you start modifying other aspects
of that so you change for instance the
activation function then you might also
find you need to change the learning
rate if you don't do that it can you get
a really bad result and you assume it
was that new activation function was no
good when in fact you just needed to
change the learning rate to match that
function but yes it's just kind of trial
and error and there are you know in the
heuristics so some of the more advanced
networks will kind of work it out
themselves that they've got heuristics
to work it out and there even our
adaptive learning rates I believe where
it will actually train itself to into
the right learning rate yes when you're
doing
rather than just feeding it okay this so
that you you mean by up here mean to the
left to the little there okay you could
try that I don't see how that could
improve it though because but by having
by waiting the working out the output
votes as a weighted sum of the input
votes that seems to capture everything
that I mean know what it would do is it
would kind of league some dirty data
back towards towards the end but because
the the the when your feed from the
output to the first hidden layer the
hidden layer itself will give the best
possible
feedback as to what the layer to the
left of that would need so I'm I'm not
sure that that would help but that's
just from a you know a really quick
ten-second evaluation because there
might be some subtle reasons why that
could work well I I do know that when it
comes to feeding forward it can actually
sometimes help to to allow stuff to leak
forwards because it can help when you
went with training very deep networks
that would otherwise not not qui s so I
mean there are subtleties like that
which often that they are discovered by
trial and error
so the input layer has intrinsic meaning
the output layer ends intrinsic meaning
the hidden layers in the in the middle
do those have any intrinsic meaning yes
yeah that's also a good question and no
they don't they well they do they mean
something to the neural network right
but they don't it's very unlikely that
it means much to us it's very hard for
us to look at what's in that layer and
and try and correlate that that's that's
got some something that's meaningful to
us it's unlikely because it's it does
represent some kind of extraction so if
you think about the the digits it could
be capturing the concept of a loop or a
concept of a of a straight line or
something but that's way too simplistic
it's probably it's the most complex and
subtle and wheel is unlikely that we
would find much at least with this style
of network is possible with
convolutional networks that we might see
me see something that was more
meaningful to us but yes it does have
meaning but not I don't think it's
something that we would would mean
anything to us as humans
you mentioned earlier that you'd be
better off having a toilet yes in what
scenarios does it best have well this
scenario certainly is better to be
taller the if you're using convolutional
layers
that's very conducive to having more
layers rather than than just being
taller and also with convolutional
layers and this may also apply to other
architectures they're not fully
connected so that's one of the
advantages is that with those that kind
of image processing you're doing is
before it feeds into the network in a
sense is that if you think of the whole
thing as one your network the neurons in
in the input layer won't work all of
them might all be kicked - every neuron
in the next layer and that makes the
convolutional networks more efficient
and I think that also probably my
intuition is that helps with with with
the depth allowing for more layers but
they're really the best way is to where
this kind of thing is to try it and see
and if don't give up too soon if it
doesn't work try do a different
activation function in there or changing
the learning rate or but it's the best
way really is to is to experiment and
see you mean in across layers yeah yeah
definitely what we just did we we had we
were using the softmax activation
function in the in the output layer so
this and then and then a Darrell you in
the hidden layer and that's quite often
done is that you have different
activation functions in different layers
that that's quite very common
you have different data for the input
legs not during one okay so in this case
well actually it was it was fractional
to err or yes it was numbers than the
input data in this case it was between 0
and 255 because that was how was
representing the the pixels right there
was a grayscale so you basically convert
it to a number a real number and then
that becomes your input yes you need to
I believe it has to be at come kind of
number before that and also that there
are the way in which you convert it to
the number can have an influence on how
successful it is because you're
effectively doing some pre-processing
which can make it much easier harder
from the new it for the network
depending on how you do that okay
believe what time maybe for one more
question and then call it quits
I suggest you download that and just
have a play with it
fiddle with it or even you could just
write that first example again from
scratch that will be the first thing I
would suggest you do is take this the
simple the simple example we had with
one year on to do the NAND gate and
start again so I'll see whether you can
reproduce that because if you can you
pretty much understand the the learning
algorithm if you can do that it's not
that hard but that's the first stage
because what you'll probably find is if
you do a cleaner and implementation of
that it won't work you'll get some basic
thing wrong and that's that's how you
learn that's how you get that you know I
did this myself I thought it was simple
I wrote it it didn't work and I realized
I didn't really understand how it worked
and that that billet I believe is a
first step now the next step if you want
to have some more fun with us is you
could say you could experiment with
different activation functions you could
it'll be really cool if you wrote a
convolutional layer for this if you do
that please send it to me okay thanks
everyone so that's all we've got time
for thank you for coming
[Applause]